welcome everyone if I could please bring
us to attention
you're making your way through the food
line we're gonna go ahead and try to get
started more or less on schedule my name
is Doug Kaiser and it's my privilege to
introduce you to our speaker for this
evenings event before I begin let me
first acknowledge the co-sponsoring
organizations for the event
the Yale climate and energy Institute
and the Yale Center for Environmental
Law and Policy this talk is part of our
climate and energy bookshelf series in
which were featuring speakers who
published recent or forthcoming books in
the areas of climate change and energy
policy
the remaining events in this series
include a talk by Jedidiah heard Purdy
next week on April 5th and by Sarah
Craig off on April 18th I hope you'll be
able to join us for those events as well
tonight we're extraordinarily delighted
to welcome dr. Daniel Yergin back to the
Yale campus dr. Jurgen is a highly
respected authority on energy
international politics and economics in
selecting him as one of the hundred
people who matter worldwide
Time magazine said if there's one person
whose opinion matters more than any
other on global energy markets it's
Daniel Yergin the New York Times
described him as America's most
influential energy pundit fortune said
he's one of the planet's foremost
thinkers about energy and its
implications
he is known around the world for his
book the prize the epic quest for oil
money and power which was awarded the
Pulitzer Prize it became a number one
New York Times bestseller it was
translated into 17 languages and it
became the basis for an eight-hour PBS
BBC television series his new bestseller
which he will talk to us tonight about
is called the quest energy security and
the remaking of the modern world the
book has been called a masterly piece of
work by The Economist it's been hailed
by the Financial Times as a triumph the
New York Times said the book is
necessary reading for CEOs
conservationists lawmakers generals
spies tech geeks thriller writers and
many others any spies in the audience
tonight
Bill Gates summed up his review by
simply saying this is a bent
dick book and during a recent appearance
to discuss the book on The Colbert
Report doctor Jurgen was lauded for
helping Stephen Colbert understand why
peak wind and running out of Sun were
not serious impediments to the
deployment of clean energy educated at
Yale and at Cambridge University where
he received his PhD dr. Jurgen is vice
chairman of IHS and founder of IHS
Cambridge Energy Research Associates one
of the leading energy of advisory firms
in the world
he's been awarded the United States
Energy Award for lifelong achievements
in energy and the promotion of
international understanding the
International Association for energy
economics honored dr. Jurgen for his
outstanding contributions to the
profession of energy economics and to
its literature he serves on the US
Secretary of Energy advisory board and
he chaired the US Department of Energy's
Task Force on strategic energy research
and development I could go on and on in
fact I spent most of this afternoon
trying to winnow his achievements down
to just that list that I gave you
let me instead conclude simply by saying
that all of us here today are fortunate
to be able to hear one of the leading
thinkers in the world talk about the
leading issues driving the world please
join me in welcoming dr. Daniel you're
gonna
thank you thank you very much for that
more than kind and generous introduction
I appreciate it I'm very glad to be here
I've learned something that it's much
better to have the food at the beginning
of the event then at the end of the
event and impressed to see that you did
mention the Colbert Report and those I
bet most people know the Colbert Report
it's a terrifying show to go on because
you know he's going to make fun of you
and but I did one thing they told me
before I go on is remember he's the
comedian and you're not so don't make
any jokes and I was fine on everything
until he as you pointed out expressed
grave concern about peak wind and what
to do about it and that that's kind of
the point where I lost it thank you very
much for the opportunity to be here to
have this discussion with you
I want to thank the Center for
Environmental Law and Policy and also
the energy the climate and energy
Institute at Yale which I'm pleased to
be on the advisory board of and it's and
I really want to thank Dean Robert post
who I've known for a very long time who
very graciously invited me last autumn
and said it would be a great thing to
come up and really this has been the
centerpiece of my visit to Yale so thank
you about very much and also although
he's not here I've known Dan Esty for a
very long time and I know keep part of
the program so this is an opportunity
and I thought what I would do this
evening is use kind of the quest to talk
about some of the major issues in energy
but start talking you know use frame a
little bit what I was trying to do in
the book when I finished the prize which
Doug referred to I wrote it was right at
the time of the Gulf crisis and I wrote
that you know the modern and mesmerizing
alchemy of petroleum would continue and
we would continue to be in the age of
oil but that was a couple of decades ago
and with the passage of time was evident
how so
had changed since then when I finished
that book there was something called the
Soviet Union doesn't exist anymore China
was an oil exporter using oil exports to
help finance its economic revolution
under dong-chil paying climate change
had no traction as a political issue it
really was hardly an issue at all no one
had ever heard of shale gas if it had
any name at all it was known as an
economic gas because it would never be
economic and oh by the way oil prices
were gonna be $20 a barrel so much kept
changing and indeed right up as I was
finishing the book Fukushima happened
the nuclear accident that changed what
was going to be a nuclear Renaissance
into kind of nuclear patchwork in terms
of development and the era what people
call the Arab Spring and now call the
Arab upheaval unfolding upsetting the
strategic balance in the Middle East and
still very unclear in terms of what the
consequences are for the region and
therefore the energy supplies of the
region so so much it changed so it
seemed like you know good idea to write
a book and the other thing I wanted to
do was look at the whole energy spectrum
and try and understand how these things
all fit together and so it was really a
learning process for me to undertake
this book as the prize is really a
process of discovery of seeing how
things fit together now
I find that when you write a book like
this it's very helpful to find what I
call the to myself at least the
emblematic personalities the people who
help carry the story and in the prize
there were more sort of swashbuckling
entrepreneurs and risk takers I have
certainly some of those in this book but
this is a geekier book actually
among the many heroes of the scientists
or the heroes of this book and there's
one person in the book to kind of give
you an example a chemist at Caltech
named Arry Hagan Schmitt I checked with
the two chemists in the room
because I want to say no one has heard
of him and I chat wanted to check to see
if they had heard of him they hadn't
heard of him so I feel fairly confident
saying nobody had heard of him at this
point but once a very distinguished
professor won many awards a great
chemist his particular interest was
understanding flavours so we figured out
where the flavour for garlic came from
wine onions
he's the man who figured out the active
agent in marijuana and it's alleged as a
statue to him somewhere in California
for that effect but he was obsessed
actually with the pineapple and
understanding the flavor of pineapple
and he was working away in his
laboratory at Caltech at the end of the
1940s and he went outside probably for a
smoke but into what was supposed to be
that beautiful California air that Bob
and I remember from our childhood which
he saw sometimes saw but instead he
encountered what he called that stinking
cloud of smog and at that time there's a
huge debate as to where if smog came
from and he said you know I'm a chemist
and I can figure it out and he said he
figured it out in the first nickel he
figured out that he came from the
improperly combusted gasoline and
automobile engines and so out of that
then started a process to regulate
emissions that well-known
environmentalist Ronald Reagan set up
the California Air Resources Board which
is probably the most powerful agency
that most people have never heard of
since it sort of regulates the world
automobile industry and the first
chairman was era Hagan Smith and started
this process that led to the institution
of the requirement for zero emission
vehicles ie electric cars and so you
know if you look at the Chevy Volts that
are coming on the road today you kind of
find that they connect all the way back
to air E Hagins MIT and understanding
where smog came from and kind of what I
was doing in this book is throughout is
trying to understand how things happened
how they came about another one another
example was a young
scientists who actually graduate it was
quite a good degree in science but the
market you know young people today know
it's hard to get jobs and the market for
academics in his field was not good he
started doing tutoring to try and earn
some money didn't get any customers he
advertised free tutoring as free samples
of children didn't get any customers his
father wrote a letter to a scientist
said you know my son grows more unhappy
day by day and he believes that his
career has been permanently derailed
that of course was Albert Einstein he
did get a job in the Patent Office and
Bern and in that remarkable summer 1905
wrote five papers that changed the world
one of them about the photoelectric
effect so he really laid out the the the
theory of solar energy of photoelectric
of solar panels and so forth it took the
space race with the Soviet Union in 1958
to actually get them put to use for the
first time as an alternative to the
batteries that were going up in the
satellites after the Sputnik and so that
was 1958 and here we are today in 2013
more than a hundred years after
Einstein's paper and solar has clearly
made great progress costs to come down
the largest solar company in the world
just went bankrupt in the last few days
as noted I even on the front page of the
Yale Daily News and it's growing but
it's still a small business and so kind
of driving home the fact that it takes a
long time in the energy business for
things to change it doesn't happen
quickly just a couple of other examples
of the personalities who are important
those who have read the book will know
that this is the only book on energy
that's ever been written and that ever
will be written I'm sure that talks
about the worst moment in Ronald
Reagan's career as an actor yes I'll
tell you about it he after his head of
the screen
guilty couldn't get work and so you know
he was sort of washed up and so the only
work he could get was doing stand-up
comedy fronting for a singing group
called the Continentals in Las Vegas it
was pretty good at the stroke telling
but actually couldn't he hated it
thought his careers over comes back to
Los Angeles phone rings it's his agent
Ronny and he has this job for him as
some in the audience will remember as
the spokesman for General Electric he
signs this contract which today would be
the equivalent of a million dollars a
year to go around just give speeches for
General Electric in his contract by the
way it says he will not fly because he
writes at the time I'm one of those
prehistoric people have a fear of flying
he overcame doubt when he got Air Force
One it made it easier to to deal with
but he the reason I write about it is
because at that point the United States
electricity demand was growing in the
way that Chinese energy demand or Indian
energy demand is growing at 10 or 11
percent a year and it was very
challenging for the United States to
meet that and one of the reasons that we
had the development of nuclear power to
try and cope with it and the the
relevance is what we see in the emerging
markets today the kind of challenges
that assured that they have the electric
power that they need is now something
that's not only of national importance
but has global impact I'll just mention
two other people that had helped tell
the story one is I sort of said well
where did wind come from where did the
modern wind business come from and I
kind of asked around a lot and
everything triangulated on this one guy
named Jim Nelson and so I tracked him
down and and asked him about it and he
told the story of how he spent Chris New
Year's Eve 1981 atop a wind turbine
tower in the Tehachapi pass in a
blizzard in California trying to get
this wind turbine up by midnight and the
reason it needed to be up by midnight is
because that's when the tax credits
expired so he gets it up
and then it falls apart but he got the
tax credit but he says there's got to be
a better way of doing this so he goes
off to Europe he thinks you know the the
Dutch have had windmills for a long time
so he says what we'll find him in
Holland but in fact he ends up in
Denmark and discovers is this industry
the sturdy Danish agricultural machinery
industry makes much stronger wind
turbines he starts to import them to
California California becomes the
epicenter as well as the birthplace of
the modern wind industry 90% of the wind
turbines at one point are in California
and so that's where the industry begins
and generous tax credits and everything
and so you know the question of where
did the modern wind industry come from
the answer is it's kind of the result of
the marriage of the sturdy Danish
agricultural machinery industry with
California tax credits that's why we
have a wind industry one well I'll save
that one other personality because
there's one other who's very important
but so those are some of the ways I tell
this story but you know those who have
you and their many here who labor on
books or even writing your your papers
know that the you have to stand back and
say what's it all about and the
challenge you know in a way I was
finding they're kind of both the easiest
of the hardest thing to write are the
introduction to conclusions because you
have to decide what is it all about and
what do you carry away and so really I
realized from this whole enterprise I
think it's really about what seemed to
me the three big questions about energy
today the first is the question about
growth that is there we go through these
cycles where we're running out of energy
where we have abundance of energy and
we've seen that again and again five
years ago Peak Oil the notion we were
kind of running out of oil was dominant
and and and I think that that belief
system kind of fed on itself in terms of
the markets today there's more
confidence about the physical supply not
necessarily what happens above ground
but on the other hand we know that
there's a challenge and the challenge is
a economic growth of the emerging
markets of these nations of
income and their need for energy and the
challenge of meeting it that probably
two decades from now the world would be
using somewhere between thirty and forty
percent more energy and how's that going
to be achieved and what's that's going
to be a mix and that of course is a
subject that for a lot of people as to
what that mix will be in the future but
so that first question is just are the
the abundance of supplies or the
shortage of supplies and you know I
would was struck when people talked
about peak oil a few years ago we're
running out said it's true we're running
out of oil it's actually the fifth time
that we've run out of oil first time
would run out of oil was in the 1880s
when the head of Standard Oil of New
Jersey said I will drink every barrel of
oil you find west of the Mississippi
they found oil in Texas Oklahoma he
forgot the promise he moved on from that
but nevertheless we've seen these cycles
that we've gone through again and again
and then things like technology and
price and new areas adjust and that's
what we've seen in the last five years
the second big question if that's the
question is there enough the second big
question is energy secure and I realized
actually sort of in one of the sessions
I had with undergraduates here that in a
way what I mean I was brought into the
energy field by crisis by geopolitical
crisis and that probably has shaped my
view the question of energy security and
the traditional issues of energy
security are still very much on the
agenda the same questions that burst
onto the scene decades ago are still
there today with the confrontation and
the standoff with Iran and the question
of what's going to happen there and it's
the same question again is the Strait of
Hormuz going to be shut or not and not
long ago the Chairman the US Joint
Chiefs of Staff said yes the Iranians
can shut the Strait of Hormuz and then
we can open it I mean in other words you
know every both sides have been through
that a great deal and you know for the
last several years people said each year
is going to be the critical year on Iran
I still find that people who are deeply
engaged think this probably might be
we're more or less than the critical
getting
close to the endgame one way or the
other so the traditional energy security
issues are there but they're kind of
three new dimensions to it one is just
physical security in terms of terrorism
and things like that and what happened
about six weeks ago in the deep in the
Sahara Desert in Algeria where the gas
plant was taken hostage by jihadis and a
number of people were really executed
and but the aim of those people was to
actually blow up this plant and create
you know just a huge fireball of
disaster and I know that what that has
done is lifted the concern about
physical security everywhere in the
world about the energy system and energy
infrastructure the second aspect of it
is kind of what call into what I call an
integrated energy shock and the first
one I think that we had at least in this
country was Katrina and Rita in 2004 and
we just had it again with superstorm
superstorm sandy in in the mid-atlantic
and the Northeast and that's a situation
where everything is down at the same
time you don't have power you don't have
fuel you mergency vehicles can't get
fuels from gasoline stations because the
gasoline stations don't have electric
power to get the fuel out and you have
the immobilization of a region and I
kind of regard these as kind of warnings
of what can happen and so this question
of preparing for these integrated shocks
so that when they do happen there's a
greater resilience I have a former
colleague who was one of the key people
in the city of New York dealing with it
and he said you know when superstorm
sandy struck New York he said we were in
the fog of war we had no information we
didn't understand what was happening I
know New Haven was affected and then of
course the blizzard and this just is a
big warning when a region is done that
the third thing that's new is the cyber
threat and it's been
recognized certainly for the last few
years but it's now at a higher level and
what happened in Saudi Arabia last
summer when 35,000 computers were wiped
clean
probably from Iran was a huge warning
the isolation the wall worked it did not
affect production but it could have been
if it affected production it would have
created a panic in the world and I think
for for the energy industry this was a
real wake-up call
former Defense Secretary Leon Panetta
warned of the risk of a cyber Pearl
Harbor and then in the in a State of the
Union address President Obama the number
one issue and that he cited in terms of
cyber threat was the threats to the grid
so there is I think this kind of sense
that you know that that there's this
vulnerability there in the system and
and I know the electric power industry
the oil and gas industry trying to cope
and prepare but there is a sense of
great alarm about this and the nature of
the risk the third big question is of
course the environment question the
climate change question and it seems to
me that climate change did not really
gain political traction I mean there was
a Kyoto treaty in the late 1990s but
really not until the turn of this
century that it really gained the kind
of political traction that we now see
where it has become such a key defining
issue for the entire energy sector so
it's those three questions that that
kind of are the three prisms that I
guess I look at energy through and then
you can look at the kind of specific
developments that are happening in the
world that fit into that and there are a
couple that a few that I want to kind of
site that are really important you know
we have when people move into an office
building they have something to call the
build-out and the build-out is you
decide where the windows will be and
where the Xerox room will be and where
the offices will be in all those things
I know we have
here from China I think China is going
through something that's never happened
before the build out of a whole country
that is 20 million people a year moving
from countryside to city and when you do
that that means you need energy you need
energy for transportation you need
energy for work you need energy for
building and so that kind of creates the
this this embodies what's happening with
rising incomes and emerging markets and
for me what kind of the simple numbers
that tell the difference of how things
are changing is automobile sales in
China versus the United States in 2017
million new cars were sold in China in
the United States and two million in
China
ten years later 17 million in China and
12 million in the United States and that
kind of change is being replicated
across the world and is where the real
demand growth is and so we all know the
phrase globalization but I think one of
the things that I focus on is the
globalization of demand it used to be
when you would look at energy balances
people would write about oacd and then
they had ro w and ro w was the rest of
the world
well now the rest of the world is
actually using more oil than the OECD
countries and that's the kind of shift
that's happening the second area where
this shows up is in terms on is on the
geopolitics and the security issues and
despite the growth of supplies elsewhere
in the world the Middle East is still
the kind of the center of world supplies
and there are many factors there that
create question marks for it as I said
obviously the unfolding of the Arab and
evil in the region the youth bulge the
distribution of population I have a
chart in the book that compares the
distribution of population in industrial
countries and the Middle East and it's
you know it's very dramatic where you
see this large young population that
doesn't have jobs and doesn't have
opportunities and is a huge source of
uncertainty in those countries
clearly al Qaeda
it's affiliates and that's what was at
work in Algeria and then Syria which not
an important oil producer itself but
what happens in Syria the results there
will affect the whole region beginning
with Iraq Turkey Israel but perhaps the
Gulf as well and then the question of
Iran is as I said we have sanctions that
are in place on Iran they've worked more
successfully than was thought but that
doesn't mean that there's going to be a
some kind of settlement to address the
issue of Iran's nuclear ambitions and so
I think that just kind of hangs over the
whole region it goes in and out of the
news so the geopolitics I want to turn
to the technology side of it you know
because I think for me as I think about
kind of other themes and takeaways I
mean the two things that I feel that
I've learned from this is one you know
from this whole enterprise on energy one
is that price really matters I had lunch
today with a group of economists and
they thought that was a really good
conclusion to come to it took me a while
to get there and the other is technology
really matters and so you know wind and
solar are when we talk about renewables
it's wind solar and biofuels those are
the main things out there right now in
terms of electricity it's wind and solar
and I describe the birth of the wind
industry then the Renewable industry
really went through something that
people who are part of that industry
referred to as the valley of death in
the late 1990s where people hung on by
their fingernails and then this rebirth
occurred and the rebirth came about
partly because of climate change
concerns partly because the need for
energy to meet growing energy needs and
partly technological progress because
you just realized that those industries
of the 1970s 1980s and 1990s were very
immature industries so and then Germany
was really the country that stimulated
the rebirth of renewables and it's a
it's a big business now last year was a
hundred and sixty seven billion dollar
business
however with that said it's gone through
it's had a period of great optimism and
I think it's now under more pressure in
an age of austerity because while costs
have come down dramatically it still
does depend upon government budgets and
kind of there was kind of a green bubble
that started around 2004 or 2005 and I
was very struck by a comment this week
that the head of CalPERS the largest
pension fund in the United States said
because they had a really aggressive
program to invest in renewables and the
chief investment officer said it's
turned out for them to be a noble way to
lose money kind of a stark phrase about
it
Teli so you know we're in another period
and I think a lot of the things that
have been launched now at the technology
frontiers and some of you are involved
in they're gonna take ten or twenty
years to come to fruition but so I think
it's a period of kind of consolidation
and pressure for the Renewable industry
those industries were born in the 70s
and 80s if you said what was the biggest
technological the biggest innovation in
energy since 2000 is shale gas you know
it's just in terms of its scale and its
impact if you're measuring it just by
its impact and this is another really
remarkable story of how it came about
and again it's sort of one man sort of a
Steve Jobs of hydrocarbons I guess we'd
say this man named George P Mitchell who
is a Texas not an oilman but a gas man
and he believed in natural gas and in
the early about 1982-83 he read an
article as I understand it that
suggested that you couldn't extract
shale gas from shale rock and this was
considered crazy but he also had a
contract he had to deliver gas to
Chicago and his fields were running out
so he had an economic incentive as well
and he kind of had enough control over
his company to kind of his a very
stubborn man and so the guys working
from said George you're wasting your
time you're wasting your money
he said it's
money I'm gonna do it and he continued
to do it but took 15 years to get the
breakthrough 15 years to get the
breakthrough in hydraulic fracturing and
then it took they needed capital so the
business got then purchased by another
company called Devon which had another
technology which was horizontal drilling
and the two things came together in 2003
sort of proof of concept and from there
it grew but it wasn't very visible
people thought we were the United States
was going to import large amounts of LNG
and spend a hundred billion dollars a
year to do it lo and behold 2008
suddenly instead of continuing to go
down US gas production goes up and
people say you know my goodness this is
uh this is not what we expected and
that's when the large companies enter
the field so today it's really it's gone
from being 2% of our gas supply in a
decade ago to 37% it's changed the
economics it's brought down gas prices
dramatically it's brought down
electricity prices as well
it has also well I should maybe I'll
pause in the environmental aspect so as
it's kind of as everybody knows it
started become a subject of
environmental controversy so President
Obama had a commission set up to look at
the environmental side of it and I was
on it as chaired by John Deutsche had
been the Provost of MIT and Deputy
Secretary of Defense etc and we look at
the different environmental questions we
have hold lots of hearings site visits
and everything and come to the
conclusion that that the concern about
chemicals as a scientist on it say is
extremely unlikely to have any effect
that the three main environmental
questions are what do you do with
wastewater what about air pollution air
quality and what about Community Impact
lots of you know trucks coming into
community and say that each of these is
subject to remediation each of them is
subject to regulation each of them is
subject to best practices and technology
and kind of that's what's unfolding as
we talk now there's a big argument about
whether the state should regulate
regulate this or the federal government
should rate
like this and that to me at least to the
Americans in the audience it kind of
reminds me as I sitting in all these
hearings two years ago I kept thinking
of the Federalist Papers we talked about
there was a role of the national
government and the states and I think
it's kind of that argument goes on but
so there has been a lot of addressing a
lot of effort some companies along with
the Environmental Defense Fund have now
set up a center just a week ago for
sustainable shale development I think
it's called
to kind of focus on best practices what
you need to do about water what you need
to do about air quality what you need to
do about your diesel engines trying to
address this range of questions but that
develops in but then there's once people
see it's working for sure shale gas they
said well what about oil so they go they
go to this place called the Bakken in
North Dakota which is just you know just
a few barrels of oil and start
developing it and suddenly we see that
the same technology is really
dramatically changing the position of
the US in terms of oil in ways that
would not have been thought of five
years ago just wouldn't have been
thought of US oil production is up 40
percent since 2008 40 percent what does
that mean that's as much as Nigeria
produces in its entirety so this is a
big number and is starting to you know
we're seeing a rebalancing of world oil
as a result of that as well as other
developments and I'll talk about in the
Western Hemisphere
but it's interesting from a political
point of view and an economic point of
view to see the kind of shift that's
gone on because the focus and I can see
it in Washington and I can see it it was
very evident in the in the presidential
campaign the narrative has changed to
focus on the economic significance of
what's unfolding because the numbers 1.7
million jobs supported by what's
happening in this unconventional oil and
gas revolution the United States
becoming more competitive I know when I
was in Europe and you talked to
you know leaders of European business
very concerned about their ability to
compete now and and very loath to make
new investments in Europe there are
other reasons too but partly because of
also this loss of competitiveness as the
u.s. because of low-cost energy so it's
kind of having this impact on the global
economy now the question is is this
unconventional revolution just a North
American Revolution I think it varies
around the world and some countries I
think I'd see my my observation is China
is a country that has greater resources
in this than part of the United States
won't happen overnight we'll go ahead
interestingly Saudi Arabia is investing
in shale gas so that they can use in
electricity and have more oil to export
Ukraine Mexico has great potential some
countries have said no like France
England has said yes but it's going to
be slow to develop I think in the rest
of the world but it is there's no reason
that technology is going to stay here so
there are three three things that are
happening the Western Hemisphere that
are changing oil and the changing and
rebalancing of world oil in a very
interesting way
one is what I've already said what's
happening in US oil and now you know I
don't know if it's gonna happen but
people are predicting 2017 2020 that the
United States will be producing more oil
than Russia more oil than Saudi Arabia I
think it whether it gets there or not I
don't know but it's going to be a horse
race and you know that wasn't expected
the second thing is the growth of oil
sands the amount of oil sands in Canada
now the output is greater than Libya was
producing before the Civil War and maybe
in the question period we'll have a word
about the Keystone pipeline because I
know it's on people's mind and the third
is what's happening in Brazil with with
the pre-salt
and Brazil now has the capacity to be
producing more oil than Venezuela and
being the oil powerhouse so this
rebalancing of world oil that's now
happening has a lot of geostrategic
connotations it's early but it's you
know people are struggling to understand
and what it might mean you know so these
are some of the dimensions I talked
about there's one other I want to talk
about and it's something that has always
been a huge focus for me which is the
energy efficiency side of the equation
what happens on the demand side and it's
something that I've focused on over the
years and in fact us like other
countries has made a lot of progress the
u.s. is twice as energy efficient as it
was a few decades ago same for Japan
other countries but and the potential I
think is there we have tools that we
didn't have before and I think of energy
efficiency is really an energy source
and it's just a competitive with others
but there's one big problem with energy
efficiency and it was brought home to me
by the European energy commissioner when
we're at a big renewable energy
conference in Washington and he said you
know renewables are great but boy we
could sure get a lot of impacts quick
from energy efficiencies that just
there's just one problem and I said
what's the problem he said there's no
red ribbon to cut there's no photo
opportunity you there's nothing you know
beautiful windmill you can photograph
you can photograph a plan there's
nothing to photograph although I did
actually
in the quest put it in a picture of
chrome Hall as an example of an
energy-efficient building and it's very
very handsome building so I think these
are some of the to me kind of the major
themes that are unfolding you know
there's a big question for everybody
what kind of cars will people drive in
ten years will they be more efficient
automobiles well there'd be hybrid will
they be electric cars will they be will
they be natural gas vehicles we had a
conference a couple of weeks ago and I
had the CEO of General Motors there
asked him that question and his answers
I don't know you know you got to invest
in all of them because this is moving
but I think the fact that our automobile
fleet has to doubt about double fuel
efficiency is a really huge thing in
this country so I mentioned when I
started that you know the issue figuring
out how you want to what do you want to
leave readers where
then what do you want kind of leave
yourself with and this issue of
innovation is really the one that I find
most compelling because when you look at
this broad history of energy over the
last couple centuries it's all about
innovations that come along that aren't
expected that changed things and I found
a character to help held that story and
his name is sadi carnot engineers will
know the Carnot cycle but but he himself
is not no known he died quite young in a
cholera epidemic and his papers were
burned because of that but he was a
scientist and engineer and in 1824 he
published a paper called the motive
force of power and he wanted to explain
how the steam engine worked he wanted to
do it because he's the scientist and
engineer he also wanted to do it because
he was a soldier his father had actually
been Napoleon's Minister of War and he
thought that one region that Britain had
defeated France and then the poliana
quartz was because of its mastery of
technology and he wanted to teach the
French to bring them up the learning
curve on this and so it's interesting
that even then energy and geopolitics
were entwined and I found this wonderful
phrase in which he talked about what he
said that what's happened unfolded with
the steam engine what he called the heat
machine and combustibles he said was a
revolution in human affairs and
revolution in human civilization and it
seems to me that that really is in many
ways the story of of energy in a way to
look at it and it's one that actually
fills me with optimism because of work
that people here and many others who are
here in this room and others are working
on that the that we will that there's no
reason that innovation is going to stop
we're gonna see breakthroughs we're
gonna see things differently and so that
this and that we have something else
going for us too that we didn't have
before which is the globalization of
innovation it's not just a u.s. project
and maybe a Western your project it's a
Chinese project it's an Indian project
so
there's a lot more talent involved in
looking at these questions and this is
talking to some you can work virtually
around the world on these problems in a
way that wasn't possible before so this
kind of great revolution in human
affairs I'm convinced will continue and
it has to continue in order to meet the
challenges of the future and the needs
of a growing world economy Thanks